Marines are without a doubt one of the single most
powerful groups of fighters in all of One Piece,
so we are going to rank the fifteen ABSOLUTE
strongest marines in the entire story.
And we cannot make this list without including
the very first person to ever truly defeat Luffy
on his quest to become pirate king. This
chain-smoking, fiercely loyal marine is
Vice-Admiral Smoker, who was always set up
as Luffy’s main marine rival from the very
start of the story. And besides effortlessly
overpowering Luffy at the start of the story,
he has grown strong enough to even fight on equal
footing with a Warlord of the Sea. And you know
what's even cooler? Smoker's smoke devil fruit
powers were the very first logia abilities we
ever came across. Plus, I CANNOT imagine that
he is done climbing the ranks of the marines,
because after Enies Lobby he basically just
decided it was time to stop messing around
and soon after he was promoted to Vice-Admiral.
Which is one of the reasons I'm totally convinced
that by the end of this crazy story, he'll be one
of the strongest new generation marines around.
However, while Smoker is on the rise, he still
pales in comparison to the jaw-dropping feat
of Vice-Captain Tsuru. And that’s because
Tsuru is simply a legend in the marines
whose reputation is on par with some of the
strongest marines, like those who are coming
up at the top of this list. In fact, she is
so well respected that even the foul-mouthed
Doflamingo cannot help show her courtesy. And
while her Wash devil fruit isn’t the strongest,
she is ABSOLUTELY one of the most extraordinary
tacticians in the entire marines, and she
undoubtedly played a pivotal role in developing
the battle plan during the epic war at Marineford.
And I cannot wait to talk all about
the insane marine fighters who took
part in the war, but before that we have the
self-proclaimed best defender in the world,
Sentomaru. This sumo-inspired character
is the ultimate bodyguard of the world
government’s genius scientist, Dr.
Vegapunk. He is an amazingly powerful
fighter who even showed off the first use
of advanced armament haki in the story,
but you know what’s even crazier? His true power
lies as the commander of the Marines science unit,
which includes the cyborg Pacifistas and the
genetically enhanced Seraphim clone. Seriously,
anyone who can control these mind-blowing
powers can basically win wars all on their own.
However, while Sentomaru eventually got
washed by these relentless government agents,
this next marine put up a way tougher fight
against these masked enemies. And for the
longest time we didn’t even know that Diez Drake
– aka X Drake – was a marine. That’s because he
was actually an undercover captain working for
the secret marine organization: Sword. And let
me tell you, this man is an absolute monster who
became a world famous pirate equal to pre-time
skip Luffy. He is an incredible fighter who dual
wields this impressive ax and sword and can also
turn into this enormously powerful dinosaur with
his Allosaurus devil fruit. And to top it off,
he got so strong that he became one
of Yonko Kaido’s top officers before
flipping sides and helping turn the tide of
the battle during the raid on Onigashima.
But Drake isn’t even the strongest secret
marine in Sword, and that’s because at
number eleven we have the character who
might very well be the strongest marine
ever by the time he reaches his full power.
That’s right, this right here is the future
fleet admiral. But if I’m being honest, while
Koby started out as a pretty pitiful weakingly,
his growth rate in the story is simply RIDICULOUS.
I mean he went from being this crying little kid
to an absolute chad in just a few years and
at this point can even stand up to Yonko like
Blackbeard without backing down And while he
doesn’t have a devil fruit, he is a master of
observation haki and I wouldn’t be surprised if
he eventually becomes the strongest Marine ever.
However, he’ll have to wait to climb the marine
ranks, which is also the sad fate for these two
marines right here. And you may have even
forgotten that Gion and Tokikake exist,
and we certainly don’t have
any impressive feats for them,
but these two vice admirals were specifically
mentioned as candidates to take the two vacant
admirals spots during the time skip. Which means
they must be incredibly strong if they barely
missed the cut to be considered on the same
level as these next marines in the ranking.
Which brings us to the incredibly hyped admiral
tier, which has ALWAYS been portrayed as absurdly
more powerful than your everyday marines. But
at the bottom of admirals’ tier is the meme,
the myth, the legend, Admiral Greenbull. Even
though he is constantly made fun of for being
scared of Shanks and being an Akainu fanboy, he is
undoubtedly powerful with his forest Logia powers,
which he can use to grow deadly vines and giant
forests in the blink of an eye. In fact, he even
took on the entire guardians of Wano and easily
fought the commanders of the Revolutionary Army.
And the man fighting right beside him – or
ironically, sometimes against him – in the
clash with the revolutionaries is the blind
admiral Fujitora. But don’t be fooled by his
disability because this man will straight up
drop a meteor on your head with his gravity
devil fruit powers. And this devil fruit power
is truly op, which is why it barely missed the
cut for my top 5 devil fruits ranking. For
example, Fujitora can use its powers to fly,
effortlessly crush opponents, lift giant heaps
of rubble, and combine gravity with his sword to
create devastating attacks. Plus his observation
haki is SO strong that he can basically see by
sensing the people around him. However, his
strength isn’t even the most important part of
his character because Fujitora is also a man on a
mission to rid the marines and world government of
corruption. He frequently disobeys orders that he
doesn’t think are good and even desperately worked
to disband the entire Warlord system after he saw
what Doflamingo did to the country of Dressrosa.
And unlike the next marine on this list, if you
want to stay free of world government corruption
make sure to subscribe to the channel for
more one piece content just like this.
Unfortunately for this former marine admiral, he
never had that opportunity, because he left the
marines after his crew was completely wiped out
and the government didn’t care at all. And while
Zephyr never officially appears in the manga,
he is the main antagonist of Film Z, although
it is basically confirmed that his backstory is
canon. That’s because during his time as a marine
he became a famous trainer who brought along the
many of the marine prodigies still to come on this
list. And with everything we see in the film, he
certainly is a devastatingly powerful fighter on
par with many of the legendary older generation
of marines. Zephyr mainly brawls with his fists,
including his super destructive mechanical arm,
and is a master of haki and Rokushiki techniques.
Though even this overpowered master eventually
got taken out by his student because admiral
Kizaru showed up at the end of Film Z and wiped
out his former teacher. But don’t feel bad for
Zephyr because Kizaru is a true weapon
of destruction who might actually own the
title of defeating the most pirates in the
entire story. The light fruit user can kick
at light speed and shoot out incredibly powerful
beams of light which he used to almost take out
the entire worst generation of pirates on Sabaody.
And honestly I would love to have even a fraction
of this man’s confidence because he straight up
wanted to go to Wano to take care of Big Mom and
Wano BY HIMSELF. What a madman. He is also the
only marine to remain an admiral both before and
after the timeskip and is undoubtedly going to
play a major role in the future of the story.
Which is precisely what we hope for Kong,
who could either be the strongest marine
in history or just some random dude who loves
his oversized fish tanks And while that second
option is highly unlikely, I mean COME. ON. Can
we get any remarkable feats for this man? I even
considered putting him much lower in my ranking
because even I sometimes forget about this dude
because he has done literally nothing in the
story despite his impressive resume. What we do
know is that he is the current World Government
Commander in Chief, who has complete control of
both the Marines and Chepier Pol agencies. Plus
he was the fleet admiral during Roger’s era,
so we should expect him to be strong since the
Fleet admiral is promoted from the admirals
and you only get to that point by being
super strong. I mean also, he’s one of the
buffest dudes in the story, but that clout can
only take him so far. But maybe the only time
we ever saw Kong get pissed was when the next
marine on this list turned in his resignation.
And it may surprise you that I
have ranked Sengoku over Kong,
but in my opinion Sengoku has always been
massively underrated just because he gets
overshadowed by the number one figure
on this list. But this afro man was the
former fleet admiral, he fought against
Whitebeard and Roger in their primes,
he is a great tactician who was smart enough to
out maneuver Whitebeard during Marineford. Plus
he has the Golden Buddah devil fruit which can
send out giant shockwaves and has always stood
out to me as something that might have some super
secret powers we have yet to see in the story.
Which I know that’s kinda hard to believe,
but you will probably be even more shocked
by who is ranked above Sengoku on this
list. That’s because next up is Aokiji,
the ice logia fruit user. And while he may
not be a marine anymore after joining the
Blackbeard pirates, we just have to include him
because of the possibility that he is working
undercover. And this man is an absolute god.
His devil fruit powers are so OP that he nearly
wiped out the straw hat crew after Skypiea,
he can easily fight on par with the Yonko,
and even a super powerful character like
Doflamingo didn’t want to mess with him.
But what’s most impressive is that he
fought for TEN WHOLE DAYS against Akainu,
who is our next strongest marine in my ranking.
And this epic clash of ice and Akainu’s magma,
these two literally changed the terrain of an
entire island. However, Akainu eventually won
this legendary clash, so we just have to rank
him slightly higher. And it is fully deserved
as he has what the author called one of the
most destructive powers in the entire story
with the magma devil fruit. I mean this power is
so strong that Akainu could literally punch off
half of Whitebeard’s head. Along with a ton of
other impressive accomplishments, Akainu is the
current fleet admiral and just HAS TO BE one of
the final antagonists for the end of the story.
Which is insane that there is another even more
powerful marine, but I simply could not rank this
one any lower. He was the rival of Gol D. Roger,
took out Rocks D. Xebec, and even wanted to kill
Akainu himself during the war at Marineford.
I’m of course talking about Monkey D. Garp.
And we see just how insanely powerful he is
in recent chapters when this old Garp - who
is not even in his prime anymore - basically
wiped out half a Yonko’s crew plus an admiral
level character by himself and used his advanced
conqueror’s haki to destroy this entire town with
a single punch. But while this particular
moment showed off Garp’s ridiculous power,
it still didn’t make my list of top thirteen
conquerors haki moments in the story. But if
you want to see which legendary moments did make
the list, you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.